but to get back to what you were saying
yesterday about people going to
Wisconsin and voting yeah in the middle
of this pandemic really putting their
lives on the line and you said well if
they do that both by mail perhaps we'll
have voter fraud in this country that's
one of a three voters in five states you
talk Colorado Hawaii Washington and
Oregon all vote by mail can you or the
White House staff wear your campaign to
fight any evidence to back up your claim
the mail-in voting is white with broad
like the example you gave of people
working the rooms filling out a false
balance is very fair and where's the
evidence the I think there's a lot of
evidence but we'll provide you with some
okay and there's evidence that's being
compiled just like it's being compiled
in the state of California where they
settled with Judicial Watch saying that
a million people should not have been
voting in you saw that did you weigh
excuse me well I'm just telling you I'm
telling you in California in the great
state of California they settled and we
could have gone a lot further Judicial
Watch settled where they agree that a
million people should not have voted
where they were a hundred and fifteen
years old and lots of things and people
were voting in their place what I see
and you know every one of those states
that you mentioned is a state that
happens to be won by the Democrats and
if you have a position like me where
it's registered you're here and we're
voting someplace where I'm not I haven't
left the White House and I guess months
other than to you know ask a ship to you
know wave it goodbye to New York
which by the way is now going as you
know being used for the purpose that
we're talking about which a lot of
people wanted what a minute
well for the Republicans certainly
hasn't but if you're a senior citizen
and if you're somebody that needs it I'm
all for it but they have to be very
careful because you know the things with
bundling and all of the things that are
happening with votes with by mail where
thousands of votes are gathered and I'm
not going to say which party does it but
thousands of votes are gathered and they
come in and they're dumped in a location
and then all of a sudden you lose
elections if you think you're gonna win
I won't stand for it
well we're gonna find out about the
proof because you're gonna see what's
going on and I'm not going to stand for
it our voting system first of all we
should have voter ID when you vote you
should have voter ID and if you send
something in you should be sure as a
state and as a country you should be
sure that that vote is meaningful and
it's not just made fraudulently because
there's a lot of fraudulent voting going
on in this country this country should
have voter ID